are we are we oh we're going chain we're
chaining them hey let me just hold one
can I hold one can you light one and
just let me hold it
let me just soak up some of that [ __ ]
cans you know what I mean
for people who don't know you're not
like a regular smoker but these are
special these are special I don't know
why I'm going so fast on them right now
I gotta uh ration these things out I'm
gonna just take one pool just to keep it
lit
that's the first time I've ever smoked a
cigarette actually when I was eight did
you you gotta bite that first one a
little Tangy part
no you gonna hear it
look at it you see the little orange
part that's not I'm not comfortable with
anymore all right here you go yeah
here you can put this out too I'm just
kind of wasting it or you can just take
it I don't want it
you're just gonna waste my [ __ ] like
that man
yeah that's some [ __ ] it just you know
what I understand the appeal of it
though I feel like I'm in a movie
I feel like we should be there should be
like green lights and pool tables around
yeah I feel you survive strange women
you know what I mean maybe some whiskey
yeah but I'm not trying to push push it
on nobody don't [ __ ] with it it's just
trash
I just happen to like it yeah I respect
it hey whatever so uh you're still a
heavy smoker on the on the on the ganja
yeah
papers only still paper's only Still
Still tells the game until the day I die
yes